the Prince of Providence tells the story
of the former mayor of Providence Rhode
Island Buddy Cianci credited with
improving the city's economy he faced
federal racketeering charges served jail
time and had alleged ties to organized
crime author michael stanton spoke
recently at Brown University for about
an hour and a half good afternoon
everybody and welcome to today's talk by
and discussion with Mike Stanton the
Providence Journal reporter and the
author of the Prince of Providence my
name is Pat Nick Wigan and since 1995
I've been the executive director of the
Providence plan also teaching a course
here at Brown and was asked to introduce
Mike and say a few words and I want to
start by acknowledging and thanking our
sponsors and hosts the Brown University
bookstore and the tabman Center for
Public Policy for pulling this off and
bringing us together today I got a call
actually an email about a week and a
half ago asking if I would introduce
Mike and the kick that's off I'd
actually just bought the book and was
reading it and said I'd sure I'd love to
except I've never met him I don't know
him and they said well you don't really
need to know him we would just like you
to talk about some of your experiences
because prior to working in Providence I
worked for more than ten years in Boston
with mayor Ray Flynn and Tom Menino so
it's been the last 20 years of my life
working in Boston and Providence with
mirrors and they thought I would have
something brief and useful to say the
book tells the good the bad and the ugly
about Providence for the last 10 years
I've actually worked in the city and had
a chance to work with and work for many
of the people here and Mike has done a
really wonderful job of capturing some
of the day-to-day and the realities of
what goes on whether you care about
urban policy and the challenges facing
Providence and cities like it whether
you care about politics and sort of the
down-and-dirty and real people doing
real things to get real votes or really
whether you care about people in power
because this is really a story about a
man Buddy Cianci and his attempts to win
power the whole
Vonda power and to use and ultimately
abuse power it's a fascinating story I
think as we often realize truth is
stranger than fiction and I think this
really testament to that I care a lot
about Providence I care a lot about
cities and I think it's important that
we learn how to do this better and I
think mike has really given us some very
helpful and thoughtful ideas he's taken
a journalist eye which is often much
more valuable than in academics to
really understand what's going on the
story of Providence is playing well the
Renaissance is really quite
extraordinary and the book is doing well
Mike was telling me that he's had a
chance to talk to folks mostly in New
England I think tomorrow on the New York
Times it will be for the third week at
least in a row or third week on the
bestseller list at number thirteen so
there's a national audience for the
story which really I think just goes to
show that it's not just about Providence
but it's about people trying to figure
out how to turn cities around and what
are the challenges and opportunities
that we face I said I worked with lots
of these folks and knew them but reading
them through Mike's eyes is a whole
different way of understanding and I
think he's really done an extraordinary
job of bringing stuff to light that even
folks of us who were working really
closely with the mayor and with the city
never saw so it's a great story and a
great read if you haven't be sure to
pick it up mike has done a wonderful job
as you all know he's a Pulitzer Prize
winning reporter from the Providence
Journal he's the author of the Prince of
Providence and I'm happy to introduce
Mike Stanton
thank you and thank you all for being
here I should tell you that I grew up in
outside of Hartford Connecticut and
Providence in my childhood was the
proverbial smudge on the highway to Cape
Cod as The Wall Street Journal put it in
the early 80s during what we all now
locally know as buddy one and I I didn't
really know Providence except to speed
by to visit relatives in in the Cape in
summertime and I just remember this very
kind of foreboding place with these old
rusty freighters in the bay and you know
traffic moving very quickly and old you
know red brick warehouses baking in the
Sun and triple-deckers it looked like
they were gonna fall down on themselves
and Providence did have that image this
would have been the sixties in the 70s
and I didn't know it until much later
but it was then the capital of the New
England mafia and one of the most
powerful mafia families in the country
Raymond Patriarca as I discovered was
actually the unofficial mayor of
Providence he owned cops and judges and
politicians he controlled a
multibillion-dollar gambling empire that
stretched out to the casinos of Las
Vegas and down into the Caribbean and
actually all around the world and it's
interesting that Jimmy Breslin once
wrote that Providence has the best
thieves in the world and he was
referring to some of patriarchy's men
who were known as boosters who would go
out around the country like the old the
fishermen of old and they would go
trawling through the luxury department
stores of America and they would steal
suits and find clothes women's and men's
and bring them back to their hotel room
and clip out the labels and shipped them
back to Providence their catch as it
were where one of the biggest offenses
on the East Coast Alfredo the Blind Pig
Rossi would sell them off the rack out
of his you know apartment off Admiral
Street and judges and lawyers and
politicians would go and buy their suits
hot off the rack their buddy cianci
years later once said after the
Providence Police arrested two Bank
robbed
that they didn't even take what you can
make it a decent fundraiser and he's
right but he also said back in the 70s
when he was battling with the Democratic
City Council and he was the Anti
Corruption candidate and a Republican
and he was there were three members of
the council who opposed him who had been
convicted of various crimes including
one who was doing a insurance fraud
scheme another guy from the hill who was
related to a mob guy named Joe onions
and the City Council president Bob
Paxton who at San C's behest had been
arrested in a car and charged with a
morals offense involving a young boy and
Cianci said when this battle was coming
to a head and what I described as the
Wednesday night massacre he said that
the incidence of convicted felons in the
general population is one in 30,000 on
the Providence City Council it's one in
eight and this of course was before he
too became a convicted felon in an ugly
you know gothic horror story of a night
where he tortured a man at his carriage
house on power street with his armed
police bodyguard standing by and his
public works director and his divorce
lawyer as audience who he suspected of
having had an affair with his estranged
wife and the most brutal aspect of that
was when he tried to stick his lit
cigarette out in the man's eye and the
man flinched and it singed his eyebrow
and this was obviously before Cianci was
forced to resign for that crime and
before nearly two dozen of his
supporters and some key advisors went to
prison or were convicted for various
corruption but the story of Buddy Cianci
really is this roller coaster saga of
American politics of American crime and
really passion a passionate love affair
that he carried on with this city
this prototypical American city from for
nearly three decades I like to think of
Buddy Cianci as a larger-than-life
character in a stranger than fiction
city equal parts Huey Long and Tony
Soprano
a man who could have gone far who in
fact was early in his career destined
for the United States Senate who was
actually talked about as possible
presidential timber who actually went to
Ronald Reagan once an audition as a
possible vice presidential candidate but
his inner inner demons and the cesspool
of corruption that was Providence kind
of dragged him down and kept him here
where he became known by the judge who
sentenced him to prison last year as dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde a man who really
embodied the best and worst of American
cities and politics and what we all
aspire to and seek to avoid and of
course Cianci who was never you know
short of a one-liner
his rejoinder to being called dr. Jekyll
and mr. Hyde was well how come I didn't
get to F and pay checks so C C and C to
me is a great story and of course then
he headed off to prison and he referred
to it as a very very inexpensive spa
where he would lose weight and you know
not drink so much because their wine
list was quite limited there but when I
set out to write this book it was about
two years ago when San C had just been
indicted in a two-year old federal
corruption investigation by the FBI
known as Operation plunder dome and I
initially thought that I would focus on
that case and the idea of this Perils of
Pauline politician once more faced with
this obstacle and would he survive or
would he go down and and with her
Providence in this remarkable
Renaissance and questions such as you
know human corruptibility and redemption
and that were explored in Robert Penn
Warren classic novel all the king's men
and what would become a buddy what it
would do the ends justify the means at
what price Renaissance how genuine is
the Renaissance because he was a
national poster child for that and so I
initially set out expecting I would
chronicle that case we even a little bit
of his background but as I dug into the
history of Providence I really realized
that my lifelong love of history and
politics was about to be fulfilled in a
way I'd never
imagined because I really went back to
the roots of Providence and I think I
concluded that to really understand
America you have to understand
Providence for all its quirks in a lot
of ways it really can tell us about who
we are and to understand Providence you
really have to understand Buddy Cianci
because he really represented the city
and it's good and it's bad and it's
quirkiness and it's bizarreness for
three decades I like to think that
America or that Providence was America's
first safehouse back in colonial times
Roger Williams was expelled from
Massachusetts by the Puritans for his
heretical ideas and he came through the
wilderness to the head of Narragansett
Bay and he found that this colony called
divine providence on a motto of hope and
he welcomed in all the people who were
not accepted the people who are
different who were rogues who were
outcasts the Baptist's and the Quakers
and the Jews and he built this really
rich vibrant thriving society down here
that really did become the model for how
America evolved both in terms of its
religious freedom and also in terms of
some of its not so admirable qualities
along with the tolerance you had an
acceptance of corruption and loose
business practices Cotton Mather
referred to Rhode Island as the [ __ ] end
of creation the sewer of New England the
other colonists this you know disparaged
us as rogues Isle and we became this
place of slave traders and rum runners
and bootleggers later the Industrial
Revolution began here the
entrepreneurial entrepreneurial spirit
that made the state great in spite of
its small size fueled this you know what
I call the Silicon Valley of the early
20th century we were one of the leading
industrial giants of the world at that
point and fruit of the Loom the great
textile company began here and it was
that industrial revolution that that
brought in the tide of immigrants which
is another strain of the American story
the Irish came in the English and the
Italians and the Portuguese and the
French and smaller groups as well and
Buddy Cianci grandfather Pietro Sanz
was a carpenter from Raqqa Mon FINA in
Italy near Naples a little hill town and
he came in that wave at the turn of the
century and he worked building the new
provenance for the immigrants and he
moved to Silver Lake on the fringe of
the city which was kind of a step up
from the crowded tenements of Federal
Hill and he had about a dozen children
one was a would grow up to be a doctor
the first in the family to go to college
a great immigrant success story and he
was dr. Vincent Cianci the buddy's
father and buddy was born in 1941 you
know as World War 2 was breaking out and
transforming Providence yet again and he
grew up in this really kind of romantic
Damon Runyon world where the textile
mills had all moved south the factories
were dying the inner city was dying and
Raymond Patriarca came to power as the
mafia boss and the King and I kind of
drew on my kind of romantic memories or
foreboding memories as well at
Providence driving through as a child
when I you know was trying to capture
that era and a couple of paragraphs that
that I had written early on that I tried
to really you know work around as I
described that era I went back to AJ
leveling the great New Yorker writer who
worked as a reporter at the Providence
Journal during the Prohibition years and
he recalled a waterfront line with flop
houses tattoo parlors and Portuguese
ship Chandler's stores where smugglers
ran scotch right up Narragansett Bay he
wrote that the best liquor was to be had
of a bootlegger who had a flat and a
frame building behind the Statehouse he
felt a responsibility for the quality of
the legislation that got passed under
its influence and when Buddy Cianci was
ten years old his father brought him to
the old smoky Rhode Island auditorium to
see Rocky Marciano fight the future
heavyweight champ who fought most of his
professional fights in Providence where
he was friends with Raymond patriarch of
the mob boss who he went to after
someone stole a fur coat out of his car
he knew where the real power was in
Providence
and I described the patriarch as
post-war provenance as a wide-open town
that lived up to its colonial reputation
as rogues Isle a city of hustlers
gamblers and ward Heelers with a film
noir skyline that curled like a fist
around the head of Narragansett Bay the
great ships that had once circled the
globe no longer visited the rotting
piers that jutted out into the bay like
a prizefighters broken teeth and and
that to me was the provenance that but
he grew up in and came of age in and his
father wanted him to follow in his
footsteps and become a doctor instead he
just he was drawn to politics to the
stage as a child he was a childhood
performer took singing and dancing
lessons in a studio behind City Hall
downtown appeared on Cecilia Moreau
skitty review every Saturday morning at
the outlet department store downtown and
another future future star who performed
in that review was Ted Knight who became
famous on The Mary Tyler Moore Show and
sanity was born to be a performer and he
was born to go into politics and he
became a Republican he went to work for
a Republican Attorney General and he
became an anti organized crime
prosecutor and in one case I found very
fascinating he had a hand in prosecuting
Raymond Patriarca for ordering the
murder of two bookies in a silver lake
meat market not far from where buddy had
grown up these bookies had refused to
pay tribute to Patriarca fueling a
bloody mob war in Providence that was
really making headlines in the 60s there
was a you know a real mind set up on the
hill the Federal Hill Little Italy that
you didn't cooperate you didn't talk
about murders or you know what you saw
because it was better to be judged by 12
and carried by six and they were
fighting that culture so this
prosecution of Patriarca became a huge a
huge trial this was really their chance
to try to put away the mob boss and
Patriarca pulled an ace out of his
sleeve at the last minute in the trial
he brought in a priest to testify as an
alibi witness for him saying that he had
been with the mob lost the day that the
government's star witness said he had
ordered the murders and this seemed to
be a pretty you know dramatic blow to
the state's case and just as they were
about to do closing arguments but he
decided to call down to the priests
parish down in Maryland and check out
the story he discovers that the priest
had been baptizing a baby girl down in
Maryland the day he said he'd been up in
Providence with the mob boss and there
was a baptismal register and polaroid
photos to prove it so they went to the
judge they pleaded for a delay in the
closing arguments the judge gave them
until the next morning but he gets on a
plane with us with a local Providence
police detective they raced the Mafia
down there they actually bumped to mob
guys off the last flight out of
Providence to Washington mob guys
chartered a Learjet beat him down there
but but he it had the foresight to call
the United States Marshals who actually
went to the church rectory in Oxon Hill
Maryland and guarded the baptismal
register which is now the birth of a
baby girl had become evidence in a
double murder in Providence and I talked
to this Gentile Church woman who kept
the register and she described her
Terror at seeing Buddy Cianci come
barreling into her lace-curtain rectory
with cops and you know smelling of
Cologne and cigar smoke and they're all
drinking gin and he's telling her about
this guy's The Godfather of New England
and and all cuz she could think about
was that she had just seen the new movie
out that spring The Godfather a few
weeks earlier and she kept thinking she
told me about that horse's head in the
bed and she was terrified but ciency
gathered her up and got the priest who
had been transferred to a nearby parish
and he negotiated with the Archbishop of
Washington who wanted immunity for the
priest but buddy called back to Rhode
Island to his superiors who were
indignant and the Jewish prosecutor who
was in charge of the case said there
ain't no way I'm making any deal with
any you know you know what priest
get him back here so buddy brings the
priest and the church woman and a few
other people and the parents of the baby
girl brings them all back to Providence
the next day and their motorcade kind of
makes its way in from the airport and
buddy was a young man then he was about
thirty years old and he cut a very
swashbuckling figure for a young
prosecutor
he had money because his father had been
wealthy and he had his own chauffeur
driven car he had a black Lincoln car
and the chauffeured car meets them at
the airport tarmac and they Breeze in to
Providence courthouses ring with shot
gun toting police officers in case
someone tries to break Patriarca out
Patriarca had actually been offered
asylum by Papa Doc Duvalier the Haitian
dictator in his jungle retreat because
they had a casino together down in Haiti
but patriarch had figured he'd beat the
case so he didn't need that sanctuary
and the bookies were laying odds in his
favor that he would beat it and so they
put the priest back up on the stand and
the priest very meekly recanted his
story and said that he must have been
mistaken and so that kind of negated
that bomb that the defense had dropped
on the state however this being
Providence there were some holes in the
story of another witness that the state
had put on and the jury ultimately voted
to acquit Patriarca and you know
ironically it turned out that the
witness whose stories had holes in it
later had been coached by a renegade FBI
agent who would later pop up in the
whitey bulger scandal and in Boston you
know about 20 years later so things have
a long history in Providence but Cianci
goes on to be the first Italian made
American mayor in Providence in 1974 he
runs this historical race against Joe
Doorly who was the 10-year incumbent but
the Democratic machine was the Irish
Democratic machine that had run
Providence since the Great Depression
was cracking the city was dying there
was a sense that nobody was really doing
anything to help it anymore Lyndon
Johnson's Great Society programs had
dried up without really turning around
some of the urban decay in America and
Doorly became known as no dojo and he
had this split with mr. Democrat the old
Ward boss Larry McGarry who ran Public
Works and doled out the jobs and kind of
kept the Machine in order but they had
this fatal split and there was a lot of
intrigue in that election because the
idea of voting for a Republican was
heresy in Providence and so people
secretly worked for CN cn there's one
scene where CNC meets up with some
Allari McGarry supporters one night and
he's his campaign managers driving a van
and the three supporters are waiting on
a dark street corner downtown at night
and one of them is wearing a trench coat
another one is wearing Groucho Marx
glasses and the mustache so he won't be
recognized and they drive around the
city at night and they talk about how
they're gonna carve up the patronage and
how CNC will protect all the Democratic
machine jobs that Larry McGarry if
McGarry puts his support behind him and
so he does and so CNC runs is the
anti-corruption candidate and yet he
also understands that he has to make
deals with people to get power that it's
not enough to just win the votes of the
East Siders who are the reformists up on
the hill around Brown University he has
to come down from that hill and cross
the river the Providence River that he
says is like this democratic machine
that it stinks and he has to cross that
river and he has to go into the wards
and he has to get the votes and he's got
to get the machine on his side and so he
cuts deal and he cuts corners there's
one of his as he later tells a story one
of his supporters was a black city
councilman from South Providence which
is a destitute neighborhood named Lloyd
Griffin and he was nicknamed satchel not
only because he looked a little bit like
the great Negro League Pitcher satchel
page but because he would bring in mail
ballots by the satchel and dump them on
CN C's desk and the first campaign he
went around to all the senior citizen
projects and he signed up you know
thousands of them to vote for CSE and he
did this in part by promising them a
free bus trip to Atlantic City and so
they all signed up and voted for CNC and
then the appointed day for the bus trip
came and bad news bus drivers went on
strike no bus trip well there was no
strike that never had been a bus trip
and years later Cianci would cynically
laugh about that kind of as a you know
knowing wink and nod about how you
played the game of politics well let me
tell you a little bit about the
Providence that CNC became mayor of it
had one of the highest unemployment and
unemployment rates in the country I had
one of the highest alcoholism rate the
day he was inaugurated on the
steps of City Hall he looks over to the
old Jazz Age Biltmore Hotel where Rocky
Marciano and Duke Ellington had stayed
where Raymond Patriarca as a 16 year old
had been a bellboy and where he had
announced his campaign in the garden
room and he saw their workers wheeling a
grand piano out and the hotel would
closed a few weeks later he the zoo was
in such bad shape that the year before
he was elected Buffalo escaped and were
obscene roaming down the highway monkeys
escaped from the zoo and were running
loose in Providence the Bible study
storefront downtown actually closed its
doors because there were no souls left
to save high school kids would drive
around the closed department stores and
pull the mannequins out of the dumpsters
and smear the legs with ketchup and
stick them out the trunk of their car
and drive around pretending they had a
body and the police wouldn't even pay
attention so this was the scene this was
the Providence that Buddy Cianci
inherited and he injected with his
enthusiasm and his charisma he injected
a new air of excitement and hope into
this city he opened the doors up to
people who had been you know barred by
the previous administration he brought
Antoinette downing the grande Dom of
East Side preservationist who really was
responsible for preserving a lot of the
historical and colonial architecture we
have here in Providence and he brought
her down in his limousine and all the
East Siders are sitting around
butchering his name with their proper
English and calling him Chauncey and
Cheon Chi and he kind of leans over his
desk and says it's Cianci you'll get
used to it and the hotdog lady who sold
hotdogs on a street corner downtown
who'd been banished by the previous
mayors cops but he pulls up to her one
day and buys a hot dog and view of the
police and and she was back the senior
citizens who couldn't get the banks to
cash their social security checks came
to Buddy and complained but he called
the bank presidents on his speakerphone
and threatened to withdraw the city's
deposits and the banks capitulated and
cash the senior citizens checks there
was this merry chaos whenever he was in
the office if you saw his car outside
anyone would wander in the flower lady
street people job seekers on st.
Patrick's Day one of his former police
drivers tell
me about reporting for his first day
driving the mayor and green beer is
flowing through City Hall drunks are
staggering in the quarters and he steps
into Sandy's office and he sees this big
burly work man in overalls wrestling on
the floor with two cops and sanity comes
bursting out of his office and
shirtsleeves and demanding to know
what's going on here and the carpenter
who's drunk just starts blubbering mayor
mayor I need a job I can't get a job and
so buddy says get off him and they bring
him he brings him in his office and
gives him a job he goes to Nashville
Tennessee or the Fraternal Order of
Police is having its National Convention
and he campaigns in politics and brings
in New England clam chowder to convince
them to to vote to have their convention
in a few years in Providence and he out
bids other cities like Phoenix and Las
Vegas who's mayors of course don't
bother to show up and that was the Buddy
that people came to love and and you
know and hope and he also was a
Republican and he became a protege of
President Ford this was a rarity in the
Republican Party and urban ethnic mayor
and he was someone who was seen as you
know he could get votes that the
Republicans needed as they rebuilt after
Watergate he goes to the national
convention in Kansas City in 1976
delivers a well-received speech Dick
Cheney Ford's chief of staff sings his
praises he goes to the White House meets
with Gerald Ford who wears one of those
hideous plaid suits from the 70s he's
seen as a rising star in the Republican
Party
someone who's destined for the United
States Senate where he'll have a long
run and become a national figure
he also circumvents the Democratic City
Council that's fighting him on every
step blocking his appointments he gets
federal money from Ford and creates his
own Office of Community Development and
hands out jobs and projects and grants
to neighborhood groups who had been
denied by the Machine in the past and in
the process he sidesteps the City
Council but he also brings in a lot of
remember he's still alive with some of
the old machine bosses so he brings in
some of the old bosses and cronies and
so it's this really weird mixture of
idealists and
political hacks and you know I'll just
read you a graph here about the mayor's
office Community Development in its
second year of operation the FBI began
investigating allegations of federal
funds had been diverted to pay
contractors to repair private
individuals homes in its third year the
federal government caught off funding
for a three-mile bike trail from
downtown through the east side after the
city ran afoul of competitive bidding
competitive bidding regulations one of
the overseers of a bike trail sat at a
desk in his downtown office an older
tattooed man who had been given a job
because he needed health insurance one
day the man walked over to the water
fountain and dropped dead of a heart
attack the director also remembered a
group of grubby demolition contractors
coming into the conference room and
sitting around the table rigging the
bids to knock down dilapidated buildings
eventually eventually the reform-minded
East Sider who ran the office quit and
disgusts tired of meddling from the
mayor's office later one of San C's
federally funded hires was arrested for
defrauding homesteaders to move into
abandoned buildings when police did a
routine background check they discovered
that he was on parole from prison in
Massachusetts for kidnapping and rape he
also had another sideline he ran a
string of prostitutes who worked the
streets of downtown Providence in sight
of City Hall and on rainy days the
hookers took shelter in the homestead
boards offices on Washington Street
so sandy had this duality as he sought
power and sought to bring Providence
back he would go to the opening of an
envelope he said the groundbreaking of
an aunt he would do whatever it took to
get jobs he would and he could move in
different worlds the inner demons that
drove him to succeed and ultimately to
fall were kind of intertwined with his
upbringing he grew up you know an
italian-american but a rich kid and the
blue-collar in Silverlake neighborhood
the boys in the neighborhood would taunt
him they'd you know step on his white
bucks they'd mess up his clothes they'd
shove him around he was a little lord
fauntleroy figure then his parents who
wanted him to accedes ship them across
town to the east side to the private
prep school moses brown where he would
be you
going to school among wasps and Yankees
and their children some of whom he later
lamented would never invite an
italian-american kid to their house for
parties so he was someone who never
really quite fit in either world and yet
he later
you know credited that experience with
giving him the ability to move in
different social circles and years later
he would spend a lot of his time up at
Brown University he always loved going
to graduations marching in the
processions excusing parking tickets of
the graduating seniors he loved he lived
on East Side for most of his adult life
and he resented when he felt he was not
accepted by the wasps he called them
members of the lucky sperm Club there is
a scene he told me about once when in
the 90s he's meeting with all the you
know Brahmins and business leaders
trying to get aid for Providence and
they're at the Turks head club and old
blue blooded establishment and it's 8
o'clock in the morning and he of course
scoffs that all these guys are up early
and they're all eating you know eggs and
toast and bacon and of course buddy
who's a nocturnal creature is just
drinking tomato juice and Alan
Hassenfeld is there the CEO of Hasbro
toy company and as buddy tells a story
Hassenfeld tries to give him a little
lecture on fiscal management and buddy
just kind of turns to him and says look
you make effin toys I have a police
department I have a fire department you
make effin toys and the only reason you
do that is because your father died and
left you the company because you're a
member of the lucky sperm Club so he had
those those strains running in him and
you know they eventually brought him
down I'm just gonna read you the opening
of chapter 5 that I think kind of
captures the two worlds he tried to move
in in the spring of 1979 there was a
sense within but within Rhode Island's
political world the Buddy Cianci was
going places with his decisive
reelection he was positioned for a move
up to the big leagues the governor's
seat seemed within his grasp but the
little mayor had bigger ideas he wanted
to be vice president of the United
States late in March
Nancy flew to Southern California for
what he said was a vacay
but he was secretly there to audition
for a spot on the 1980 Republican
National ticket he visited his old
political benefactor former President
Ford in Palm Springs and also met with
Ronald Reagan one of the GOP contenders
for president CNC sold himself as
someone who could win votes in
traditionally democratic areas with the
vice-presidential pipedream however
never panning out it spoke to his desire
to move in high-powered circles he might
have been the mayor of Providence but he
was also someone who when in Palm
Springs could drop in on Frank Sinatra
no matter where he went though
Providence never seemed far away in
Sinatra's Palm Springs home CNC noticed
a picture of Raymond Patriarca the New
England mob boss on the wall when
Sinatra's bartender heard that CNC was
from Providence he asked how's Raymond
back in Providence the grind of being
mayor could be draining despite seeing
sees tremendous vigor shortly after his
California trip CNC was back at City
Hall welcoming a new card and gift shop
downtown announcing improvements to the
dog pound leading an anti-litter
campaign the mundane tasks of being
mayor that seemed far removed from being
a statesman governor's aren't like this
he complained one day they can keep
people at arm's length here the people
leaned over your desk and you can smell
their armpits but in Providence buddy
was the man
when Sinatra wanted help getting a
friend's child into Brown University the
chairman of the board turned to see NC
not Patriarca as CN C's told the story
according to a former aide Sinatra
called him one night between sets of a
concert and asked the mayor to intercede
at brown CS he pulled some strings and
Sinatra's friend's kid became an ivy
leaguer in the spring of 1979 when
former San Francisco Mayor Joseph Alioto
came to the Verrazano Day banquet
honoring Cianci as its Man of the Year
he paid homage to the Prince of
Providence San Ysidro of Alioto around
Providence and when he showed on the
fourth ward joked if Machiavelli were
alive today he would be a politician in
the Fourth Ward quipped Alioto since
they elected a Republican mayor I'm sure
that Machiavelli is alive and living in
City Hall if Machiavelli had been around
he might have reminded San C of his
dictum the first impression that one
gets of a ruler and of his brains is
from seeing the men he has about him
cnc and his quest for power
in a springboard to Washington had
surrounded himself with a motley crew
thugs and mob associates and political
wheeler-dealers with their own scams and
agendas he had married himself to Tony
Buchi the Fourth Ward kingmaker who
favored expensive silk shirts and used
his political connections to build a
downtown law practice and CNC relied on
a cast of characters with names like
buckles and blackjack to bring in the
votes and sell campaign tickets and help
him control the patronage rich public
works department when they weren't doing
the mayor's bidding they were extorting
snow plow contractors and shaking down
garbage truck dealers stealing asphalt
and perfecting the art of the no-show
job a proud provenance tradition they
were looting City equipment right down
to the manhole covers which were sold
for scrap metal they were trading
contracts for cash rigging bids
consorting with mobsters Ronald Glantz
San seized top aides said that San C
also tolerated corruption for another
reason because the Mayor was the biggest
crook of them all Glantz said that he
was an eyewitness to the corruption at
City Hall that he was buddy's bagman and
I go on in that chapter to describe
glances accounts and and some others I
also talked to about what they described
as San C's role in corruption and and
again that contrast that for instance
Henry Kissinger is coming to Providence
to a reception at buddy's house on the
east side this contractor I spoke to who
became embroiled in corruption says that
he did about $10,000 worth of repair
work on the house to fix it up and he
didn't get paid and the way he made his
money back was to pad a contract to fix
a city swimming pool the same contractor
and some police I talked to described
the night that former President Ford
came to the Providence Marriott for a
fundraiser for CNC and all the usual
dignitaries business leaders the bishop
the political establishment are there to
greet the the former president but also
there are the characters like the
buckles and the you know the ward
Heelers and and after they shake hands
with the president they adjourned to the
bar or a couple of them proceeded to get
into a drunken fight over a woman and
one of the combatants as an off-duty
Providence cop who pulls his gun
suddenly the place is swarming with
Secret Service agents they're all taken
to jail and later
they're let out they laugh about where
else but Providence can you go and meet
the President and get arrested on the
same night so as many people know the
the legendary roller coaster ride took a
steep dip in the mid-80s when Cianci was
convicted of this infamous lit cigarette
and fireplace log assault he didn't
actually Club him with the fireplace log
he lifted it as if to do so and then
someone fended off the blow but that
seemed to be the end of him but then he
found a new home on talk radio became
popular there are always people who
missed him who wanted him to come back
in 1990 he made a triumphant comeback
that The Wall Street Journal called the
envy of Richard Nixon said he never
stopped caring and then he presided over
what became known nationally as the
Providence Renaissance he vowed to make
the most of his second chance and it
seemed that he had the rivers were moved
the railroad tracks were moved a new
waterfront brought people downtown water
fire became an internationally acclaimed
exposition he nourished the arts and
culture he funded restaurants that
became the envy of larger cities and won
national renown
Providence became hailed in magazines
ranging from money to girlfriend's a
lesbian publication is one of America's
most livable and tolerant cities and
Cianci was the maestro as I described
them moving around in his
chauffeur-driven limousine with the case
of marinara sauce in the trunk and
occasionally a shotgun and a fire helmet
so he could go to fires he became the
longest running lounge act in American
politics
he was the longest-serving mayor in
America he was a character who was known
in Hollywood on Broadway he won an
honorary Tony Award he went out to
Hollywood and brought movies here he
would do anything to accommodate
filmmakers the Farrelly Brothers told me
a story about filming their movie Dumb
and Dumber
in Providence and CMC offers to close
down Interstate 95 so that they can film
Jim Carrey driving out of Providence on
his cross-country journey they declined
the offer realizing that the chaos it
could create but that showed the Cianci
would do anything it took and his vision
and if
his vision sometimes exceeded his grasp
well that's okay
his former economics development
director told me a story about the mayor
being in San Francisco at a mayor's
conference and visiting Chinatown and
being so dazzled that he came back and
in spite of provenances negligible
Chinese population he demanded a
Chinatown in Providence and he is a you
know ree-ree joined her to his economic
developments director was I want pagodas
and so nobody could could fault him for
thinking big and if occasionally he was
a bully he was our bully he kind of you
know softened the edges of his you know
bully personality and he became kind of
this lovable rogue he was a regular on
the Don Imus radio show where he became
kind of a national celebrity and I miss
with tease him about how you let a guy
on fire and Buddy would come back and
say well in Providence we like people on
fire every night you know the delay of
cigarette had kind of morphed into water
fire you know an art artistic exhibition
and he paddled around with Anthony Quinn
the actor I described him as orb of the
mayor they would go out drinking late
into the evening Quinn of course moved
here late in life and and he and CNC
struck up a friendship and Quinn told me
before his passing last year that you
know he'd never met a man or an artist
who had bigger visions or dreams for a
place than buddy sands he had for
Providence and you know Quinn had met
buddy back in the early 80s when he came
to Providence to perform Zorba the Greek
fittingly and buddy showed him around
town and said we're gonna move this
river and do that restore this building
and and went you know Quinn thought he
was nuts but he liked his company and he
came back in the 90s and behold he had
done all this and then of course it all
came crashing down the FBI came knocking
once again southern FBI agent from
Mississippi Dennis akin who had never
even heard of Rhode Island when he was
first assigned here in the late 70s
later climbs to become the FBI's top
expert on public corruption he's the
head of the public corruption unit in
Washington he writes the FBI's manual on
investigating corruption he learned from
an FBI agent who had worked on the
famous
Abscam investigation of congress or air
you know undercover agents disguised as
Arab sheiks took bribes from members of
Congress and he comes back to Providence
because he misses the action on the
streets he's married a woman from Rhode
Island and he drops back down into the
middle of the Renaissance in the mid 90s
and it doesn't take him long before he
starts looking at sort of a dusty corner
of the Renaissance the West End where a
mob associate named Eddie Buccola who
ran an auto body shop that had been a
kind of a home for all sorts of crimes
from insurance fraud to a chop shop to
you know beating up insurance
investigators from out of state and
saying this is Rhode Island will blow up
your car and kill you well he turns that
auto body shop into a little gold mine
where he leases it to the providence
school department as a registration
Center for schoolchildren so these
school children are trooping down this
dilapidated neighborhood past a strip
club into the former auto Bay's where
mobsters would come for dealer plates
and registering for classes into cola
pockets over a million dollars for this
lease through the 90s at least it's an
see sign and during this lease of a coal
is arrested yet again for insurance
fraud and a witness against him gets an
animal tongue sent to him in the mail
piccola goes to prison the city rent
checks keep coming the feds garnished
the rent checks to pay the colas a
prison restitution and Aiken starts
looking into this doesn't smell good he
recruits a businessman named Tony
Freitas a Portuguese native who would
come here in his teens built the heating
and air conditioning company near of a
colas garage had actually been outbid by
Viva Cola or had lost out to the cola on
one of these city leases and Freitas was
angry enough that he agreed to do
something that no sane person would do
in Providence he agreed to wear a wire
into City Hall and for the next year he
worked with Dennis akin where it with
this very sophisticated gadgetry hidden
microphones a hidden camera in the
handle of his briefcase and he captures
CMC loyalists and officials taking
bribes on camera including Frank
corrente who was San seized top aide and
chief political fundraiser and this
actually comes to a head with a deal
one of the tax officials that Freitas is
talking to says he's meeting with the
mayor and for a ten thousand dollar
payoff the mayor will agree to let
Freitas have this vacant lot he wants to
purchase from the city and the FBI
actually sends Freitas into City Hall
one day with another agent in coveralls
disguised as a work man and fortuitously
Freitas had done some hair conditioned
air conditioning work at City Hall so he
was able to get into the Attic at City
Hall with the master key to City Hall on
a ring and they make a wax impression of
the key to the mayor's office and the
plan is to sneak in under cover of
darkness one night and plant hidden
cameras and microphones and try to see
if they can capture the mayor on camera
taking the bribe although interestingly
the mayor according the later indictment
would have the money delivered to
underlings in any event Freitas's cover
is blown before they can attempt this
and someone makes an anonymous call a
jealous girlfriend perhaps of one of the
corrupt tax officials so that blows his
cover so the case goes public and that
begins this two-year struggle for ciency
to survive and I'll just read one last
part and open it up to questions but I
was really struck by this as this case
unfolds Anstey's ability to
compartmentalize and to continue to be
the maestro of the renaissance and to
try to defy gravity with this looming
federal case he sells his million-dollar
mansion on power street he sells his
quarter of a million dollar yacht the
yacht that he would was once chased off
the set of meet Joe black for trying to
cruise into camera range and they were
filming down on Warwick neck and they're
against it Bay he moves into the
presidential suite in the Biltmore Hotel
where he had begun his political career
years earlier and it really struck me it
was like Arthur Miller's The Death of a
Salesman where he talks about you know I
met the mayor of Providence in my hotel
in Providence and you know I said you
got a fine city here mayor and he he had
coffee with me
and now here's buddy everybody's buddy
known to all living in the presidential
suite at the Biltmore like a traveling
salesman and sitting alone often at the
bar at Davio's downstairs
in the spring Davio's the bar in the
Biltmore Hotel drew an eclectic
nighttime crowd tourists conventioneers
gays traveling salesmen and Brown
University professors in the spring of
2001 Buddy Cianci could be found many a
night drinking alone there a few years
before when the playwright Arthur Miller
was in town to receive an award sans he
had read the scene from Death of a
Salesman where Willy Loman describes
meeting the mayor of Providence in the
lobby of his hotel
now Cianci seemed to be playing the role
of the salesman reminiscing about the
days he knocked them cold in Providence
as another cigarette burned down and
wait and as he waited for the curtain to
fall the previous fall Cianci had sold
his beloved carriage house and moved
into the Presidential Suite
if the mayor's life had become a lounge
act and Davio's was he joked his living
room the cynics said that Santee was
liquidating his assets before the feds
swooped in the mayor insisted he had
simply grow tired of rattling around in
a big empty house all alone besides he
quipped living at the Biltmore meant
never having to buy another roll of
toilet paper one of the people who got
to nobody after dark was Laurel Cayce a
cabaret singer who performed Friday
nights at Davio's a tall angular woman
in her late 40s Cayce usually wore a
slinky black evening dress in matching
gloves
she did her irreverent best to create
the avant-garde Society of 1920s Berlin
she was just as likely to flash her
breasts dance on the bar or insult her
patrons anything to shake them out of
their middle-class sensibilities she
viewed the mayor as a kindred spirit
like her he was a showman always onstage
uncomfortable when the spotlight was
turned off when we're alone it's like we
disappear because no one's watching she
explained behind ciency sad basset hound
eyes she saw a vulnerable boy who wanted
to be loved who needed to feel important
she had moved to Providence in 2000 from
Newport because Cianci supported artists
understood them because he was one but
that didn't stop her from satirizing the
Providence Renaissance is skin deep or
telling her audience that she lived
between a Vietnamese restaurant and a
crack house on the south side
the mayor would shout back one step at a
time Laurel late one night Cianci came
in with some friends and Casey started
lampooning them as a bunch of no-neck
thugs
the mayor egged her on urging her to do
that thing that got you fired from a
previous gig meaning flashing her
breasts last laughing
CNC guaranteed er that his companions
would all throw $20 bills if she did
instead Casey mooned them the mayor
seems shocked taken aback but that's
what true cabaret was all about she
believed a slap in the face of
convention other nights Casey would coax
the antsy to join her reluctantly
encouraged by the applause of the
audience some tourists from Omaha
perhaps or men in town for a turf
management convention the mayor would
get up and tell a few jokes or sing a
song like an old vaudevillian on those
nights it seemed see as he managed to
forget the growing shadow of plunder
dome it goes on like that but one last
story I'll leave you with before we take
questions is kind of a favorite kind of
funny story about buddy where he could
be kind of a bully but funny at the same
time and Bob Dylan is performing a
concert at the Strand in Providence in
the mid-eighteen mid-90s and buddy comes
in was entourage and sends word back
that he wants to meet Dylan and tour
manager sends word back well Dylan
doesn't meet people the only people he's
met in the last few years are President
Clinton and the Prime Minister of Israel
so word comes back to ciency who's none
too pleased and he storms backstage with
his entourage his toupee as ask you he's
been drinking and the tour manager of
Dylan demands to know who the heck are
you to come on my stage and Buddy very
matter-of-factly calmly sticks his hand
out and shakes the manager's hand and
says I'll tell you who I am I'm the
mayor of this town
see those tour buses out there I'm the
guy that can make sure the police don't
search him for the next few hours and
buddy gets to meet Dylan
and there's a million stories like that
and that's why this book was such a
labor of love because whether you like
politics or crime or corruption or
redemption it's just the Shakespearean
saga that I thought about is equal parts
Midnight in the Garden of Good and Evil
and Goodfellas so thank you very much
and the one thing I would ask is if you
want to ask questions to step to one of
the microphones on either aisle so
does anyone have any questions are you
all bashful of the microphone yes ma'am
could you step up okay well maybe
someone can hold it for you or it's
being filmed for c-span books and they
want people to be able to hear the
questions yes sir do you have any
reports from New Jersey and how buddy's
doing in prison yes I do
buddy has a five year prison sentence in
Fort Dix New Jersey and he was working
in the kitchen for quite a while within
the last few months I'm told he's been
transferred to the prison library and
he's hoping for his appeal oral
arguments are scheduled in Boston in
October and a written decision expected
sometime next year actually if you want
to ask a question I'll just repeat it
what's going on with his sauce the mayor
as many of you know has his own marinara
sauce that benefits the mayor
scholarship fund it's a nonprofit entity
the sauce is still around we're not for
sure for how long but people have told
me you can still buy it on the
supermarket shelves and so check it out
yes ma'am I am not had any contact with
him so I can't really say if he I would
suspect he's read the book and I haven't
really heard from him to say what he
thinks of it I mean I can tell you as I
write in my author's note that he did
not formally cooperate with the book I
was able to spend quite a bit of time
with him and we had our you know our ups
and downs as it were and I can tell you
one day I was in his office last summer
shortly before he had to leave office
and shortly after he'd been convicted of
racketeering conspiracy and he was
giving me a hard time about the book and
trying to tell me that if we
collaborated Random House would rip up
my contract and we'd get a new contract
for $600,000 which was much much more
than I was getting and when I told him
that I was happy with my advance and you
know it wasn't just about the money he
looked at me and dignity and said well
why not
and at one point he lectured me he said
how could you sell yourself so cheap and
we certainly had you know moments there
was a moment that 60 minutes ran where
he was upset about the book being
optioned for a movie and told me to go
play in the traffic but there was
another night that I thought was a
remarkable evening I described in the
book or the jury deliberated nine days
on his fate and he went to the gay pride
parade in Providence to be Grand
Marshall on a Saturday night in the
midst of this an enormous pressure about
whether he would survive politically and
he was a grand marshal and I was walking
along the street watching him and it was
a wonderful scene and people loved him
and we're all hailing him and he was
riding in the back of a convertible with
a drag queen named BB and he saw me
standing by the side of the road and he
said Stanton is that you and I said yes
mayor and he says get in so I got in the
car with him and I rode through the rest
of the parade and then we went out to a
bistro downtown and we drank and then he
took me to a gay club downtown were you
know nearly naked men were dancing on
stage and strobe lights were flashing
and he was in his suit with his you know
uniformed police bodyguards standing
against the back wall and he kind of
laughs and says to me he has to put his
mouth up to my ear because it's so loud
and he says you know this afternoon I
was up on Federal Hill having lunch in
the old canteen little old Italian
ladies what do you think if they saw me
now and then he joked about I wonder how
many laws are being broken in here
tonight and his photographer said well
mayor that's life in the Renaissance
City and and but he said more like
ancient Rome and then as you it was the
night before Father's Day and obviously
he'd had a very difficult family life
because of his you know he was married
to his job and and that was kind of a
tragic aspect of his life and and I and
as we were driving back in his limousine
to take me back to my car you know he
wished me well and he apologized for for
treating me badly and said I'll talk to
you and for the sake of your children I
hope you make a million bucks so you
know I saw the different sides to him up
close in a way doing this book yes sir
with this being sold for $18 at the
army/navy store in town you think if he
ever came back he would be reelected it
was legally possible I don't know I'm
not a political astrologer but I can
tell you this that one of the paradoxes
of Buddy Cianci and I think why he's
such a fascinating representative of
American politics is that the public
polls last year when he was on trial
showed that most people thought he was
guilty but they also thought he was
doing a good job so I guess that eternal
question of do the ends justify the
means would be answered yes I mean there
there is a strain and that's why I think
the story of Providence is so
fascinating because there is a strain of
corruption has always been with us it's
part of human nature and at least buddy
got things done so yes please go to the
mics doesn't work can we translate any
of this lessons learned from Buddy
Cianci to the national politics with
what's happening to the United States
today I think we can I think there is a
strain in American politics that likes a
rascal or a rogue and you know as
someone told me when I was writing about
Buddy you know we don't like our
politicians vanilla and not to compare
buddy with George Bush but certainly
there I think there was a sense in the
gore Bush campaign that Gore was just
too squeaky clean and just too dull and
he just couldn't fire people's
imaginations whereas George Bush had
this kind of playboy frat-boy shallow
image and yet people kind of loved him
because he was charming and he could
work a room even if he couldn't give a
speech which but he could he could work
a room and Buddy certainly has that
quality that that charisma that really
seems to predominate in American
politics and it is interesting that he
did you know aspire to play on that
national
stage and in fact you know he did know
presidents from you know Ford to George
Bush jr. so yeah I think that's a good
question good point
yes ma'am thank you I have two questions
one is about Providence I couldn't
understand how come the Yankee elite was
so helpless these are the Buddy Cianci
and the other question is since this
book is selling well nationally and not
just in Rhode Island
how has the writing and publication of
the book affected you well it's just
very gratifying that the people have had
this response because I really love this
story and I think he's a fascinating
character and I'm glad that people are
sharing that that interest and as far as
why the Yankee elite were so hamstrung
by him I think it really speaks to the
fact that you know they kind of checked
out of politics you know a few
generations ago I mean when the mills
moved south a lot of them I'm not saying
all of them but in substantial numbers
to really constitute a majority you know
they kind of retreated into their you
know shuttered mansions or wherever they
were and maybe some were cynical and
maybe others were outvoted I mean I
certainly there were some who were
involved but you nobody really made it
his machine and you had to be with him
or against him and if he wanted to get
anything done you had to be with him I
had a business leader who I was trying
to talk to for the book when buddy was
still in power and he didn't want to
talk to me even anonymously because he
was afraid that it would somehow get
back to buddy
and that buddy had threatened to hurt
his company he said and and he didn't
want buddy - you know interfere with
some charitable work that he was doing
in the city afraid of him because he was
vindictive he clearly had a vindictive
streak and again I think it spoke to
those inner demons that I talked about
earlier you know about wanting to be
accepted by those people but also you
know being very deferential to them in
other instances it wasn't all you know
hammer and
with him because there was one time when
he came on in a public situation and I
was sitting in the audience and he was
very witty and upbeat and taking credit
for what he absolutely had nothing to do
with and no body demurred and I asked
myself as he boasted he had four writers
in his basement writing this stuff for
him I said to myself why do I not get up
and say no way I wasn't afraid of him
but I knew that I would be a lone voice
and people would turn to me with
hostility yet I'm so dissatisfied that I
kept quiet well that's an interesting
thought I mean one of the interesting
things about Buddy Cianci is he came to
power as the anti-corruption candidate
and the darling of the Republicans on
the east side and after he became
elected and some controversy and
corruption became apparent in his
administration and some of his you know
bullying behavior turned people off he
lost that constituency initially showing
what a political chameleon he could be
in 1982 he's pretty much lost that
eastside support and he's facing a
challenge from an east side and old east
side patrician fred Lippitt and he
realizes if he runs in a Republican
primary he's gonna lose and he tries to
get his campaign loyalists like buckles
melesa to sign up his Republicans to
vote in the primary but even buckles
won't do that and that was the sign that
he had to leave the Republican Party and
and he was you know reluctant to do that
I mean there's the story I recount in
the book about you know he's at a
Republican dinner in Massachusetts with
Henry Cabot Lodge the old famous senator
and lodges slurping his clam chowder and
buddies sitting next to him and says you
eat that like an Italian and lodge says
well I am an Italian and buddy was like
scratching his head what does he mean by
that and later on a tells
that you know Cabot is descended from an
Italian navigator kobato who had helped
bring the early Puritans to
Massachusetts so he liked you know he
liked mingling with President Ford and
Henry Kissinger and John Connally and
but he did what he had to do to survive
and he became he ran as an independent
split the anti buddy vote and he won by
about 300 votes that was his third term
in 1982 and this is after he's endured a
garbage strike a financial crisis you
know scandals that had him swamped in a
race for governor where he lost every
city in town in Rhode Island every Ward
in Providence and then of course he
stood up and thanked the voters for that
mandate to keep him on as mayor and then
the city is about to go the way of
Cleveland financial catastrophe people
are screaming at him in City Hall at the
city council chambers when he pushes
through a big tax increase he's guarded
by a phalanx of police officers then to
try to save money he fires the unionized
garbage workers hires a private company
that people later alleged paid kickbacks
to him and there's a garbage strike and
garbage is piling up in the sweltering
heat of the summer and he brings in a
squadron of cops with shotguns to ride
on the garbage trucks to pick up the
trash of Providence and it's you know he
talks later he wins that strike and that
kind of turns things around for him and
he later goes to an anti labor
conservative group who's having a
conference in London England
and he talks about that experience and
here he is telling all these people in
England about buckles melesa
you know his big public works lieutenant
campaign ticket fundraiser who drives a
pink Cadillac and how buckles would he
sent buckles down to the picket line to
sledgehammer guys and stick thumbs in
their eyes and then laughs and says that
that was great public policy so oh yes
sir well you open the book talking about
you know Aikens knocks on his door and
there's 50 or more FBI agents spread out
through this small city and I'm just
wondering with the reorganization of the
FBI and some of the accusations of the
FBI cozying up to the mob in Boston what
is what is what are your comments are
thoughts on the state of corruption now
is it sort of vacuum is her this is
gonna be on the rise again correct well
what I've heard is since 9/11 one the
FBI's mission has been pretty much
devoted to that and public corruption
cases are hard to build in the first
place you're taking on powerful people
it's interesting that a RICO case
racketeering case has to be approved by
the highest levels at the Justice
Department in Washington because they
don't want any faulty cases undermining
the RICO law which is such a valuable
tool for prosecutors and so this was a
very tough case to make and and
especially when you're dealing in this
culture where you've got a parade of
City Hall officials going to the stand
you know talking about being rats and
stand-up guys and you know it sounds
like dialogue out of The Sopranos whose
founder incidentally our creator is from
Providence and and actually she double
dated junior Patriarca in college but as
an aside but those cases are very hard
to make and as the US Attorney told me
it's tough to make these kinds of cases
in Providence because nobody speaks
above a whisper and everybody's afraid
of repercussions and clearly the feds
feel that that's why they weren't able
to get to CNC in his first
administration even though there was
rampant corruption around him and
beneath him and you know as I as you're
right I opened the book the idea that
here's Dennis akin the FBI agent the
g-man standing on buddy's doorstep and
buddy sees him as just the latest in a
long line of cops who have been trying
to bring him down and and I kind of set
up this epic struggle of the book of you
know are they gonna get buddy can
anybody ever bring down buddy and
Providence you know they have too much
history together and I kind of quote the
saying on the tombstone of the great
horror writer HP Lovecraft who's from
Providence and it says I am Providence
and Buddy Cianci you could put that on
his tombstone so what it was a
remarkable case that's why I think the
public opinion polls felt that you know
he was probably guilty but they were
never gonna get him in Providence and
they just barely did get him
here's a question over here I wonder if
you can speculate on buddy's future when
he returns do you think I'll have a
public role at all that's a good
question I think it's possible I think
you know we still have to see how his
appeal plays out there certainly talked
that if he were to win his appeal he
would run for mayor again people feel
that he would win he would certainly
have a loyal core of supporters but I
think it would also be contingent on how
the current mayor is doing and it's too
soon to predict that beyond a possible
political life certainly he's a gifted
orator and has certainly been terrific
talk radio host possible local
television commentator five years is a
long time for a public person to be out
of the public eye so I think it's too
soon to say I was wondering whether
there's a there's a fixed deal with
DeNiro to play the part or whether the
part is still open for grabs the part is
still open just to catch you up the
question was about Michael Curran T the
the Hollywood filmmaker who's from Rhode
Island and he has optioned my book for a
movie and he's actively hopes to have a
be able to announce the scriptwriter
within the next two or three weeks and
he does hope to start shooting it soon
there's great interest in Hollywood it's
a great role for for an actor as has a
lot of dimensions and Robert De Niro has
been one of the names bandied about as
his Dustin Hoffman Al Pacino but to
actually say who would actually
ultimately play buddy is premature and
then some people say buddy should play
buddy
he does he does have as he pointed out
when he does have a Screen Actors Guild
card he played himself in a cameo in the
NBC television series Providence and
while he was awaiting trial not because
he was under indictment that but the
Boston Pops at their annual Christmas
concert in Providence decided to make a
change and not have him do the reading
of a night before Christmas and Buddy
was indignant about this and threatened
to cancel the concert and they kind of
sent word back and he also said well you
know I want to I want to do that and
they said well we want to use a
professional actor this time and he said
well I am a professional actor I'm a
member of the Screen Actors Guild guild
and ala I'll file a grievance and I
think that's the other dimension of
Buddy the showman that makes him so
fascinating beyond Providence and across
the country is that this is a guy who
was actually once offered his own
Hollywood sitcom called the mayor by a
Hollywood producer who happened to be in
town for business caught buddy's act
thought he was incredibly you know funny
and charming and gifted and offered him
a sitcom and also I discovered although
buddy didn't realize this that he was
one of the models for the Saturday Night
Live character the pathological liar
played by Jon Lovitz so he does have
that show business quality michael
franti related to frank currency the
former CSC aide who's in prison now for
corruption and of course he is this is
Providence he's the second or third
cousin and yes he is
but I should say that Michael although
he's from Rhode Island and may have some
relations here it gives him a better
feel for the material he is a guy who's
got a track record in Hollywood he
filmed the David Mamet play American
Buffalo in Pawtucket with Dustin Hoffman
he made the movie outside Providence
that had Alec Baldwin in it he did a
soccer film that had Michael Keaton and
Robert Duvall and of course Federal Hill
his first film the fact that the Frank
corrente from the you know the coach and
the plunder dope guy I mean he's still
in jail right and so he has not figure
into the whole the whole thing dough I
don't maybe people don't realize that
they're actually related and stuff yeah
well he did come he's made no secret of
it he actually attended some of the
trial and I mean for a movie perspective
I don't know if that really matters I
mean the focus is obviously on Cianci
and his the saga of this political life
that he led so thought to see I was just
wondering how you would compare Cianci
to other old-school politicians um I
grew up in New York in the 60s and we
had mayor Wagner at the time who seemed
like you know a decent mayor but then
years later I heard stories about him
and you know it seems to fit into a
style of old-school politics where
things were permitted that are no longer
permitted in this age of political
correctness as far as that's gonna go so
what's your what's your opinion in terms
of you know characterizing him in line
with other American politicians of that
dimension well I think he's he's a great
American rogue and in that sense I think
he fits right in with other you know
famous American mayors I mean he spans
the like you said the the death of the
old machine politics and kind of the
birth of the new telegenic soundbite
politician and he mastered both of those
worlds and both of those arts and as he
used to tell me I mean he knew Mayor
Richard Daley senior and he knows the
current Mayor Richard Daley junior who
actually went to Providence College
where one of his classmates was the
future mayor of Boston ray Flynn
and another classmate was the son of the
Cuban dictator Batista so I think
someone else had a question over here on
the right a couple of comments and two
questions one was I was at Moses Brown
on my 25th reunion at Moses Brown was
Buddy Cianci 35th reunion and when I
went to the reunion didn't a heap of
course was there and when he walked in
half the people booed so I mean it's not
necessarily that the Yankee early that's
probably the women more than the men but
it's not necessarily that the Yankee
elite was you know completely count by
him and this would was October of 91 so
he was back in office by then having
been reelected the previous November the
other one her comment was that it's
interesting what you said about him
being the son of a doctor cuz John first
story were always wanted to be a doctor
and couldn't afford to go to Harvard so
his son became the doctor that's right
buddy cianci was the son of a doctor and
jumpers story was the father of the
doctor the the two questions I had was
one how much of the Renaissance can be
attributed to jo pehli knows interregnum
between the two attempts that or two
administration's of Buddy Cianci
and the second was was it easier to get
interviews and get people to talk as
Buddy Cianci was losing power and yes I
was did you talk to people after he'd
actually left office yes I worked on
this for about two years I think that's
very true and one of the one of the
important people who who spoke to me for
this book late in the game was Wendy
materna his longtime girlfriend of about
10 years and she was with him after his
stormy marriage and divorce the one that
factored into his fireplace log
assault case
and she was with him when he was out of
office she kind of helped spew you know
convince him to make the comeback she
was by his side for the Renaissance and
then she left when it was clear that he
was married to Providence and you know
would never make the commitment that she
wanted from him and she really talked
you know obviously they had a bitter
breakup but then they've since patched
up things and he corresponds with her
from prison so she had a very
interesting perspective on him and she
was a tall graceful blonde woman
actually you know you know of loss
percent even though her father's name
was surname was materna
and very interesting perspective she
talked about the period in time in the
mid 90s when she decided to leave him
and she went down to Florida and she was
seeing another man and dating him he was
a stockbroker near Miami and she went
through this difficult several months
where she was torn between buddy and him
provenance in South Florida and she had
become the unofficial first lady of
Providence in many ways and she
described this very turbulent time when
buddy discovered that there was another
man and arrival to his affections and
his perpetual proposals that were never
you know realized and you know the night
of his comeback he got down on his knee
in his backyard and proposed to her and
she later laughed about how nothing ever
came of it but now there was a southern
man and he really started to pull out
the stops he proposed to her he wanted
to be with her he also told her that he
had had her boyfriend followed that he
would have drugs planted on his car and
have him arrested although she said she
didn't take that seriously because she
heard buddy say that about a lot of
enemies and rivals and he also insisted
that they get into couples therapy and
they went to couples therapy and she
started to feel weird because the
therapist seemed to be just telling her
to just stay with buddy and
and I talked I talked to an aide who
said that there was talk in the mayor's
office that the mayor had gotten to the
therapist whether he did or not it's
just kind of that aura of Buddy but she
describes this very turbulent you know
finish where she finally decides to
marry this other man in Florida actually
they're gonna do it in Barbados and it's
in the fall of 94 as he's running for
re-election and you know she gets cold
feet at the last minute calls him from
Florida he gets her a ticket back to
Rhode Island she comes off the plane
he's waiting on the runway with their
two cocker spaniels Tucker and Belle on
a leash and there's bows in their hair
and rather than touching her that
actually angers her because she always
hated you know making dogs look prissy
like that and this was another sign that
he never really paid attention to what
she wanted so she rips the bows out of
their hair goes so she's going off to
prudence island for the weekend to think
about things and and she and he's
stunned he said I thought you were
coming back to marry me and she says no
I need to think about it and she decides
over that weekend that she's made a
mistake calls her new beau in Florida
tearfully and wants to go back and get
married then she goes to buddy's house
and she breaks the news to him and it's
kind of a very emotional scene where
they you know they walk they talk and
they cry together they take a walk in
India point and they cry about the end
of their relationship and then she goes
down to Barbados and on the day she's
married as I write in the book the day
that Wendy walked down the aisle in
Barbados buddy campaigned for
re-election at the Providence waterfront
festival where he kissed a pig named
petunia and ironically that was the day
that a PBS film crew chose to follow him
around in the campaign trail for this a
critically acclaimed documentary on
American politics called vote for me
Mario Cuomo and Ann Richards the Texas
Governor were featured and they devoted
a segment to buddy who they crowned the
king of retail the idea that he would go
out and earn votes one at a time and
here's this public private man going
about you know campaigning on a
beautiful fall day and all the people
are coming up to him you know innocently
saying Oh how's Wendy doing and he has
to kind of tell them very sadly that
she's marrying another guy
oh good luck to her you know she
deserves it and you know guy in an Uncle
Sam costume is you know he's
commiserating with him and then he's
driving very kind of lonely in his
limousine and he's talking to the camera
crew about you know just another day you
know kind of lonely just going from one
place to place but if you don't like it
you shouldn't be in it my whole life has
been the city you know when you're out
you're out when you're in you're in and
I know what it's like to be out he's
having this kind of monologue and then
his limousine drives past the State
House and he sees a newlywed couple
posing for wedding photos bride and
groom and he says stop the limousine and
he hops out and he's very gregarious and
he greets the bride and groom who he
doesn't know and has his picture taken
with them just as he'd had his picture
taken with thousands of people before
and that just struck me as very poignant
moment in buddy's life I kind of
neglected your first question but
quickly I can say that the centerpiece
of the Renaissance was this really
historic decision to move rivers that
had been covered over by concrete the
three rivers that form the confluence of
Narragansett Bay and open them up to you
know waterfront promenade sand water
fire and Venetian gondolas you know I
have on the cover of my book of a niche
an authentic Venetian gondola that buddy
you know helped bring in and certainly
there were a lot of actors in this
historic event
a lot of federal and state and other
City urban planners and private urban
thinkers who came up with the plan buddy
signed onto it endorsed it promoted it
until he was forced to resign over the
assault he watched it from the sidelines
take shape it finished poetically as he
came back into office and he became the
show man the pitchman for it he sold it
to America so that's that's kind of his
role in it and this idea moving the
rivers had been something they'd been
trying to do for almost a century in
effect in the 1920s there was a
businessman who was going to build a new
railroad line to compete with the you
know JP Morgan and this was going to
help move the rivers and bring downtown
back but then the man went to London and
he didn't want to sail on JP Morgan's
boat coming back so he booked a you know
passage on the maiden voyage of the
Titanic and that was the end of that
plan
so the idea to move the rivers had been
around for decades so I see a questioner
in there oh yeah
instances where like this gentleman said
it Moses proud people booed him and and
you know or some what did stand up to
him and in a public forum or something
and and you know call a spade a spade or
talk you know like we here mentioned
that you know did she didn't get to you
know with The Times pub that you know of
what people actually did stand up and
even though they were afraid or whatever
particularly in the early years and and
it would be wrong to just focus on the
bully side of buddy but there's also
that part of him that wants to be loved
and accepted and particularly in the
early his first go-round in the 70s it
was a very hostile reception he would
often receive he marches in the st.
Patrick's Day parade up on Smith Hill
and you know he's the first
italian-american mayor in Providence
history and people are booing and
hissing and little literally turning
their backs on him and he just has that
smile frozen in place and even though
it's tearing him up on the inside that
rejection he goes with it I mean he
keeps coming back and that was one of
his admirable qualities that he would
always come back I mean he goes to a
church hall for a church reunion
hundredth anniversary and you know one
guy said you could hear the backwash of
boos and hisses and it was like you know
Satan was walking down the center aisle
but he just had that smile frozen in
place and he kept coming back and and
people respected him for even if they
didn't always agree with him one time he
was campaigning and he goes into the
Longshoremen's Hall down by the
waterfront tuff Union guys drinking beer
and you know he's a Republican and
they're throwing beer bottles against
the wall and and locked the doors on him
he just pushes his way right back in and
he wins their grudging respect if not
their votes you know for his resiliency
in the time thank you in the
since the eighties um I've seen
especially in the late 80s early 90s the
emerging of a hostile attitude toward
the handicapped the poor the the
downtrodden it seemed that the the
convention center the Waterplace Park
project those things that were I guess
more state and city were built on the
backs of the welfare recipients who were
forced to do without literally of
bringing them down to Ground Zero at the
time this was at the time that a couple
years after New York City New York
City's poor had been decimated by the
closing of the SROs and New York City's
subway seemed to fill up with the stench
of the homeless to a remarkable a
totally remarkable extent that totally
changed the feeling of New York City so
I saw this happening in the early 90s
starting to happen in Providence and I
wondered whether Cianci in your
experience of Cianci had a vendetta
against the poor against the bus riders
against the handicapped there was no
sense of building a huge park that we
would be totally handicapped accessible
in Providence I think we're running out
of time and so let me answer that I
don't think he had a vendetta but I
think another universal lesson of the
Providence Renaissance is that dichotomy
between rich and poor and on the eve of
buddy's trial the author Tom Wolfe comes
to a symposium at Brown University and
talks about the new American city that
he feels buddy embodies and he talks
about the psychology economy of instead
of you know factory jobs you're bringing
back a gratification and experience you
know art culture beautiful downtown
buildings but then you've got a guy
running for mayor who holds a press
conference far from the glittering
downtown Renaissance facade as he calls
it and he says real city is not the city
of Nobel Prize winners teaching at
tax-exempt universities real city is a
city of the high school
dropouts living in three Decker's real
city is not the soothing glow of water
fire it is the slinking shadows of rats
running around the neighborhood garbage
piles under a disappearing moon so there
is that dichotomy in that you know
intractable urban problems but I don't
think he had any particular vendetta
from a psychological standpoint that
there was I detected from a
psychological standpoint that Buddy
Cianci had some kind of a an inner
repulsion toward the handicapped and
that that reflected in city politics and
ultimately for whatever reason in state
politics I mean I don't know that the
state changed when Marjorie sanguine
became a handicapped person but I've
just found atrocities in this state in
regard to handicapped issues okay thank
you for coming and joined us joining us
here and I would especially like to
thank Pat McGuigan and Mike Stanton
thank you very much
Michael Stan's book the Prince of
Providence is published by Random House
their website is Random House calm